we are told that for four days you
record the number of hours you sleep
each night
you round each time to the nearest
one-fourth of an hour and then here on
this table they tell us that our
different days they tell us how many
hours we slept day one we slept seven
and a fourth hours day two seven and
three fourths day three seven and three
fourths a day four eight and a half
hours
then it says create a line plot that
shows all of the measurements on the
number line below
and it says click above the tick marks
to add dots click on tick marks to
remove click on tick marks to remove
dots so you can see if i click right
over here a tick mark shows up and if i
click again it gets removed
so let's see day one you slept seven and
one fourth hours so that's one day where
you sleep seven and one fourth so seven
and one fourth is right between seven
and seven and a half so that's right
over
there there you go
on day two you sleep seven and three
fourths hours
so that's one-fourth two-fourths
three-fourths so that's day two
day three you also sleep seven and
three-fourths hours so that's another
day that you sleep seven and
three-fourths hours
and then on day four you sleep eight and
a half hours which is right over there
and so here we go we have created a line
plot that shows all of the measurements
on one day day one it was i slept a
seven seven and a fourth hours
there were two days where i slept seven
and three fourths hours and there was
one day where i slept eight and a half
hours
let's do another example
amy ran many miles during september she
recorded how long it took her to run
each mile
rounded to the nearest one-fourth of a
minute on the table below we can see it
right over here and actually let me move
my window a little bit so you can see
everything and then it says create a
line plot that shows all of the
measurements on the number line below
all right so three times she was able to
run a mile in eight and three-fourths
minutes
so there are three that were eight and
three-fourths notice this is if we look
at the space between eight and nine
there's one two three four equal
intervals and so three-fourths is going
to be three of those one two three
she ran a mile in eight and
three-fourths minutes three times that's
what we saw from that table so that's
three times she did that
she ran a mile in nine and one-fourths
minutes two times so nine and one-fourth
that is one-fourth of the way to ten we
can see
one-fourth two-fourths three-fourths
four-fourths so nine and one-fourths she
did two times
so that's going to be one two
and then let's see nine and a half she
did four times nine and a half is here
so one two three four
and then eight and a half she did one
time
so that's eight and a half right over
there and then she ran a mile and nine
minutes five times nine minutes right
over here one two three four
five and we're done